et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Jean-François Copé bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes Le
Maire les républicains de moins en étant
enfant pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Stéphane
Vernet de westfrance bonjour Stéphane
bonjour on va évidemment parler des
républicains mais d'abord l'actualité
c'est cette hausse des prix de l'énergie
qui inquiète les Français évidemment
Jean-François Copé et qui inquiète aussi
les collectivités vous êtes bien placé
pour le savoir les dépenses pourraient
doubler pour le budget des collectivités
est-ce que vous demandez au gouvernement
ce matin des aides supplémentaires pour
les communes on va déjà faire
l'inventaire de la situation
de toute façon nous au niveau des des
collectivités locales on ne pourra pas
échapper à un plan d'économie je suis en
train d'y travailler avec mes équipes
avec mes amis élus et nous allons
évidemment regarder comment le mieux
possible faire face à cette situation
après pour le reste qui rageant et je le
dis pas simplement en tant que mère de
mots mais aussi en tant que citoyen ce
qui rageant c'est de se dire que si une
décision de réduire drastiquement notre
potentiel nucléaire n'avait pas été
prise par François Hollande et poursuivi
par Emmanuel Macron n'en serions
certainement pas là aujourd'hui et c'est
ça qui est le plus triste dans cette
affaire et qui nous renvoie un débat
presque philosophique avec les Français
c'est que quand un président de la
République ou un candidat pour se faire
élire
souscrit à l'idéologie du moment et
c'est ce qui s'est passé avec François
Hollande et le nucléaire et ben le pays
peut le payer cher pendant des décennies
on a connu ça avec la retraite à 60 ans
enfin le passage de 65 à 60 ans sous
Mitterrand les 35 heures sous Jospin la
droite aussi lorsque a été décidé de
supprimer toutes les recherches sur les
OGM c'était une erreur évidemment
historique parce que les OGM ça sert
aussi à produire avec moins d'eau et
bonne pesticides et voyez tous ces
sujets là on les paye pendant des années
et c'est ça qui est douloureux et c'est
là-dessus je pense qu'il faut qu'on ait
les uns et les autres une vraie
réflexion de fond aujourd'hui vous dites
c'est aux communes de faire des efforts
et vous le dites il y a un plan de
sobriété la préparation notamment pour
la ville de Meaux où est-ce que vous
demandez en plus des aides de l'État si
il apparaît que la situation est
vraiment très difficile et que nous
n'arrivons pas à boucler nos budgets
compte tenu de tout ce que par ailleurs
l'État nous demande de faire en dépense
obligatoire dans tous les domaines il va
bien falloir qu'à un moment on boucle la
boucle il est pas question d'augmenter
les impôts ça serait irresponsable dans
cette période où les gens ont tellement
de mal à payer pour toutes les dépenses
mais pour une ville comme comme une
ville comme la vôtre en fonction du
fournisseur d'énergie qui est suivi de
la municipalité votre l'augmentation du
prix de votre facture d'électricité
c'est quoi plus vous êtes entre plus 50%
plus 100% plus de 100%. alors
pour tout vous dire j'attends quand même
la fin de l'année pour avoir des
chiffres plus précis parce que en
réalité tout ça est à impact et les
marges ça pourrait être quoi les marches
de manœuvre en réalité c'est d'abord
faire des économies sur un certain
nombre de régions publiques par exemple
nous allons réduire la durée
d'éclairage des bâtiments publics par
exemple nous allons
affiner la gestion de nos fluides pour
essayer de faire en sorte qu'on puisse
préserver ça sauf qu'un mot on a quand
même beaucoup de chance parce que il se
trouve que j'ai fait installer un parc
photovoltaïque qui est le plus important
d'Île-de-France et qui permet de
produire l'électricité de près de 8000
habitants que nous avons un une
production de géothermie extrêmement
importante donc tous ces éléments
évidemment nous permettent d'aider un
petit peu absorber le choc mais il n'en
reste pas moins qu'il est il est
important vous évoquiez l'anticipation à
propos notamment à propos de
l'électricité il y a 32 réacteurs fermés
on a assisté à une passe d'armes ces
dernières semaines entre Jean-Bernard
Lévy patron d'EDF et le et le
gouvernement qui pour vous qui est
responsable en fait qui a mal anticipé
pour tout dire j'ai signé un éditorial
dans l'Express cette semaine pour pour
donner mon point de vue sur la question
je pense que en réalité
le politique enfin la définition pour
moi du courage politique c'est de
reconnaître ses erreurs on en fait tous
mais quand on est en politique c'est
essentiel pour partager avec les
Français quelque part la réflexion sur
la responsabilité de la décision mais là
c'est qui c'est le Macron président de
la République successifs quand François
Hollande décide brutalement à partir de
2013 après cette fée élire là-dessus de
réduire de manière programmée l'activité
nucléaire en France qui est un fleuron
de l'excellence qu'il donne en gros le
message à toute une filière des
ingénieurs les cadres les ouvriers
d'exécution qui ont un niveau de
compétence extrême dans le domaine
nucléaire c'est terminé vous serez les
derniers vous n'aurez pas de successeur
on va fermer les réacteurs que Emmanuel
Macron poursuit exactement la même
démarche il l'a dit expressif verbis en
2018 et il a prolongé tout au long de
son mandat il a fallu attendre les trois
derniers mois avant l'élection
présidentielle de cette année pour que
tout d'un coup comme si de rien n'était
il retrouve des vertus nucléaires
c'était trop tard le cri de le cri du
cœur d'une certaine manière de
Jean-Bernard Lévy président d'EDF c'est
de dire mais enfin c'est fantastique
comme si de rien n'était on me demande
de tout ouvrir on s'étonne que certains
réacteurs ne soient pas en
fonctionnement évidemment que nous avons
appliqué la décision de notre
actionnaire
ultra-majoritaire qui est l'état il y a
quand même les problèmes de corrosion
qui était inattendus vous pensez que ces
problèmes de corrosion aurait pu éviter
si la filière elle-même avait été mieux
entre nous si elle avait investi si il y
avait eu un meilleur suivi mais sans
doute mais c'est je trouve un petit peu
facile de faire peser ce poids là sur
l'entreprise qui appartient à l'État et
qui a reçu comme consigne du président
de la République de programmer la
fermeture des centrales le véritable
sujet il est là et moi je me réjouis
qu'il y a eu ce changement de cap lié à
l'urgence qui fait tout d'un coup
comprendre que quand on souscrit à des
modes ou à des idéologies la situation
les conséquences peuvent en être
dramatiques regardez ce qui se passe en
Allemagne qui rouvre depuis de depuis la
décision d'un gay la Merkel le les
achats c'est là où on se dit on marche
sur la tête donc en réalité les
démocraties si elles veulent survivre
continuer de préserver l'essentiel il
surtout que de temps en temps elles ont
fini avec ses idéologies qui font
extrêmement de mal qui sauvent peut-être
un journal de 20H parce que ça permet de
dire oui on va régler le problème mais
dès le lendemain on passe à autre chose
mais la décision elle est prise et elle
est pour des décennies pour les ménages
est-ce qu'il faut rentrer dans une sorte
de quoi qu'il en coûte énergétique pour
éviter l'explosion des factures ou
est-ce qu'il faut assumer de dire aux
Français vos factures d'énergie vont
augmenter les deux de toute façon quand
on dit quoi qu'il en coûte il faut pas
s'y tromper c'est le budget qui est payé
par le contribuable donc dans tous les
cas de figure on ne remplit pas une
bouteille d'un litre avec un litre et
demi et un moment où c'est trop donc on
s'est pertinemment qu'il va falloir
petit à petit retrouver les marges de
manoeuvre cela dit il marche de manœuvre
si on veut vraiment les retrouver il
faut de la croissance et si on veut de
la croissance il faut produire plus donc
notre enjeu aujourd'hui dès lors qu'il y
a le niveau d'inflation que nous voyons
si nous voulons éviter le risque de
récession c'est de réorganiser les
conditions de travail je le dis je vais
me faire taper dessus mais enfin c'est
la vérité dans ces moments là il faut
pouvoir produire plus donc travailler
plus travailler mieux réorganiser les
choses et il est évident que dans ce
domaine il y a réforme d'un certain
nombre de réforme de structure qu'il
faut faire hélas les conditions
politiques sont pas réunies puisque
l'extrême gauche et l'extrême droite
bloque le jeu au Parlement mais il n'en
reste pas moins que ces réformes si nous
ne les faisons pas le pays va le payer
très cher et c'est ce débat là qu'il
faut avoir avec les Français qu'on
aurait dû avoir pendant la
présidentielle et qu'on a pas eu
notamment la réforme des retraites il
faut la faire maintenant la réforme des
retraites la réforme de l'assurance
chômage ce sont des sujets qui sont
extrêmement importants sur lesquels
d'ailleurs la droite va devoir se
positionner et je ne vois pas qu'elle
puisse simplement dire on vote contre
parce qu'on est des opposants nous avons
là-dessus des rendez-vous historiques
avec les Français qui dépassent les
petits calculs politiques est-ce que la
situation a moyen terme c'est pas de
concevoir des aides très ciblées
vous avez tout à fait raison il est
évident qu'il faut accompagner les plus
modestes de nos compatriotes ce serait
folie que de ne pas dans un grand pays
qui est généreux comme la France
s'occuper en priorité de ceux qui sont
les plus confrontés à la précarité et
d'ailleurs c'est la grandeur de la
France de faire cela mais pour voir le
faire il faut aussi faire des réformes
de structure qui permettent de le
financer alors justement je vous pose la
question est-ce que vous parlez de qui
va qui va payer la note en fait du quoi
qu'il en coûte vous dites c'est le
contribuable mais lequel dans
l'endettement du pays est-ce qu'on n'est
pas en train de faire peser la charge de
tout ce qu'on est en train de de
dépenser ou de ou de ou de provisionner
aujourd'hui aux générations futures et
c'est tout à fait raison et et qui ont
été pendant plusieurs années ministre du
Budget je ne peux que suivre
raisonnement et vous dire qu'il n'y a
pas 36 manières de faire dès lors qu'il
est pas il est totalement exclu
d'augmenter les impôts puisqu'on a un
niveau de pression fiscale énorme et qui
était si on les augmente encore on va
tuer complètement l'activité économique
dès lors qu'on ne peut pas non plus
augmenter de manière infinie les tarifs
pour les raisons qu'on vient de dire les
gens n'ont pas pouvoir avoir les moyens
de le payer il n'y a pas d'autre
solution de faire des économies
budgétaires et ces économies budgétaires
elles passent par quoi par le fait de
faire des réformes économiques et
sociales qui fasse que dans notre pays
on puisse travailler plus et mieux je
prends juste un exemple très concret le
Comité d'Orientation des Retraites le
Conseil d'orientation des retraites a
dit que jusqu'en 2022 le régime de
retraite était équilibré pourquoi est-ce
qu'il l'est il l'est parce qu'en réalité
la croissance économique a fait qu'on a
travaillé plus et donc il y a eu plus de
cotisations qui ont permis de financer
les retraites et au s'inquiète pour
l'avenir parce que malgré tout
l'espérance de vie est en scalaire l'âge
de la retraite est ce qu'il est ben il y
a un moment qu'on aura trop de retraités
on pourra pas payer bon donc on voit
bien que quand on travaille plus qu'on
produit plus on peut financer la
protection sociale il y a pas d'autre
solution c'est la seule possibilité nous
avons une durée du travail qui est trop
basse aujourd'hui rapporter aux autres
pays européens nous devons absolument
prendre cette décision on ne peut pas en
permanence dire on veut rien on veut ça
continue comme ça et en même temps se
plaindre de la situation à l'hôpital de
la situation dans nos écoles de nos
infrastructures il faut faire des choix
et ces choix il faut les faire
vous dites sur la réforme des retraites
il faut qu'on aille dans le sens du
gouvernement de ce qu'Emmanuel Macron
veut augmenter la je n'ai pas
des républicains au fond de ils très
bien que c'est la solution c'est des
c'est des idées que nous défendons
depuis des années on l'a pas toujours
fait parce que de guerlas devant les
manifs les blocages on a cédé beaucoup
de choses mais c'est évidemment ce qu'il
faut faire la solution et voter la
réforme au Parlement il y a peut-être un
pas qu'il faut franchir c'est toute la
tragédie schizophrénique dans laquelle
elle est plongée en faisant le choix
de de ne pas de ne pas imposer une
nouvelle donne politique à Emmanuel
Macron au mois de juillet voilà parce
que la solution c'était quoi c'était de
dire sans nous vous n'avez pas de
majorité absolue nous pouvons l'avoir
ensemble mais pas on se compromettant en
exigeant que vous modifiez profondément
le programme puisque vous n'avez pas
fait la majorité absolue et donc vous
renforcez des réformes que nous voulons
nous à droite et à ce moment-là on
participe au gouvernement en tant
quantité politique bon ça aurait tout
changé est-ce qu'aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qui se passe on l'a vu sur la loi
pouvoir d'achat cet été les députés LR
ils ont été héroïques et c'est à eux
aussi héroïque parce que c'est de se
taper des heures de l'arbre avec
l'extrême gauche c'est un cauchemar mais
il n'en reste pas moins qu'à la fin de
la journée
qui a pas eu de noms qui ont émergé au
sein de LR pour des raisons de toutes
bêtes c'est que on votait les on votait
et on vote elle est mais qui ne s'arrête
pas été la même chose si on a vu des
ministres LR incarné qui aurait porté
des décisions et ça va se poser de la
même problème là même de la même manière
là pardon c'est la même chose pour le
budget parce que vous le disiez vous
avez terminé du budget Gabriel attaque a
proposé un dialogue au parlementaire de
l'opposition les républicains refusent
et ont déjà dit de toute façon on
devrait pas le budget vous regrettez
cette attitude mais
je comprends l'idée c'est à partir du
moment on dit qu'on est opposant si on
veut que le budget n'est plus opposant
bon mais qu'est-ce qui peut justifier
qu'on veut que la loi pouvoir d'achat et
qu'on vote pas le budget si dans le
budget il y a des choses sur lesquelles
on est en phase donc je pense que c'est
pour ça que je vous parlais tout à
l'heure d'une du d'une d'une tragédie
schizophrénique parce que en vérité je
vois pas comment les républicains
peuvent émerger être entendus des
Français en ayant cette position qu'il
aimait à mi-chemin entre les oppositions
d'extrême gauche et d'extrême droite et
puis de temps en temps quand même le bon
sens si on réforme l'assurance chômage
dans un sens qui correspond à ce que
nous défendons depuis des années et
qu'on ne la vote pas les Français vont
pas comprendre et est-ce que cette
position de principe n'arrange pas le
gouvernement une fine parce que
finalement dire bah quel que soit le
budget qu'est ce que je sois vous
propositions votre appart en votre
acompte ça permet de justifier le
l'usage du 49-3 ah bah de toute façon le
49-3 va revenir très à la mode
il est inévitable mais mais satisfaisant
pour personne mais en même temps celui
que je vous dis c'est les Français qui
ont décidé faut jamais oublier qu'à la
base de tout ça il y a un vote au
suffrage universel les Français ils ont
voulu qui est cueillaient le désordre
Parlement et ben ils ont le désordre
Parlement sur votre partie justement
trois candidats officiels avec ce type
ou une Retailleau Aurélien Pradier
depuis ce matin lequel a votre
préférence
écoutez pour l'instant j'avoue que j'ai
pas vraiment je me suis pas posé cette
question là on verra bien le moment venu
moi ce qui surtout m'inquiéter
énormément c'est le risque de
d'éclatement en fait des républicains
parce que à qui serait lié en fait à un
sujet qui de mon point de vue est le
sujet clé c'est qu'elle peut être
l'avenir de la droite telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui ça n'a plus rien à voir avec
ce qu'elle était j'ai eu l'occasion de
vous le dire dans d'autres interviews
mais enfin on avait il y a 2014 quand
j'ai quitté mes fonctions 350 000 à
400000 militants et sympathisants
mobilisés comme jamais là on est à peine
40000 donc
la véritable question c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on fait comment on a quand même
l'extrême droite à nos portes
un niveau de délinquance absolument
inadmissible dans ce pays parce que
parce que Monsieur Macron pour toute une
série de raisons c'est pas son sujet la
sécurité des Français donc
je vous assure il fait ce qu'il peut
mais dans des conditions politiques qui
ne sont pas bonnes pour lui parce qu'en
réalité tout est bon pour l'empêcher de
faire des choses et et à partir du
moment où vous n'avez pas une volonté
politique assumée au niveau du président
de la République ça ne se fait pas
Emmanuel Macron qui en passe Gérald
Darmanin la politique
c'est pas une priorité quand j'entends
monsieur Macron nous dire qu'il est très
angoissé à l'idée que le Front national
lui succède envie de lui dire mais
attendez vous avez une solution vous
savez c'est de remettre de l'ordre dans
le pays mais c'est de le porter de
l'assumer ce que ce qui est la clé de
voûte de du système donc il fait pas ce
qu'il faut pour empêcher le
rassemblement national du gagnant 2010
en 2027 que des millions de Français
votent pour le Front national il ne
supporte plus la délinquance il ne
comprennent pas la politique
d'immigration et il ne voit pas pourquoi
l'État
cinquième ou sixième puissance
économique mondiale n'est pas capable de
traiter des problèmes d'élinquance du
quotidien qui leur rend la vie
insupportable bon il y a des tas de
possibilités de faire des choses bon
j'ai encore une fois je l'ai vu à Meaux
la ville dont je suis le maire on a fait
le choix d'une police municipale armée
moi je pense pas du tout je pense qu'il
faut il faut complètement ouvrir ses
bras réargir complètement mais sur une
ligne idéologique qui soit claire et
donc il montre clairement offensés qu'on
ne participe jamais à une alliance avec
une extrême droite avec laquelle on a
des différences absolument majeures à la
fois du point de vue historique et même
sur le fond des sujets en économie sur
les questions sociales et même
d'ailleurs sur les questions
sécuritaires ou bien souvent à l'extrême
droite ça dérape même si en ce moment il
joue à être bien élevé et propre après
mais enfin la vérité c'est que dès qu'on
est là qui est le mieux à même de porter
votre ligne écoutez on verra bien je
vais comme tout le monde attendre un peu
de voir comment les choses vont se
positionner
Éric Ciotti à une position
traditionnellement hyper régalienne mais
en même temps il a tenu des propos de
complaisance à l'égard de de Zemmour et
de l'extrême droite qui nous fait tous
quand même un petit peu un peu peur
parce que c'est pas du tout la ligne en
tout cas moi j'ai défendu quand j'ai
construit l'idée d'une droite
décomplexée moi j'ai passé moi qui a
inventé le terme donc je suis disponible
d'en parler la droite des complexée
c'est une droite qui parle de tout mais
qui est étanche avec le Front national
alors je sais que c'est aote certains
nombre de gens qui là mais il faudrait
après tout pourquoi pas c'est pas Hitler
bah
il y a des principes dans la vie enfin
je veux dire
la tête des républicains étanche ne soit
plus étanche en tout cas cela va créer
forcément dans notre famille politique
des inquiétudes des inquiétudes réelles
beaucoup de gens le disent voilà et donc
il y a inquiétude derrière forcément il
y a des gens qui partent il y a des
portes qui claquent et tout ça
évidemment
va créer des schisme parce que il est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui une majorité des
militants qui restent à voter sont quand
même assez favorables cette alliance et
encore une fois c'est je peux l'entendre
mais je pense que c'est historiquement
et politiquement quelque chose dont on
ne se remettrait pas alors ce sont les
adhérents les militants les républicains
un jour de cotisations qui choisiront
leur président il y a eu un moment ce
type pendant la présidentielle l'année
dernière on l'a vu au moment de la
primaire est-ce que ce moment scioti
existe toujours où il est passé en fait
je pense d'abord que sa candidature elle
est totalement légitime d'ailleurs moi
je lui ai dit
ma position mais évidemment que dopé par
les scores que Éric Ciotti a réalisé
lors de la primaire il était totalement
cohérent qu'il pousse son avantage en
étant en fonction de la base électorale
qui est la vôtre aujourd'hui au sein des
républicains tels que vous la percevez
il a ses chances c'est lui qui va gagner
ah ben la base militante aujourd'hui
pour en tout cas une partie du
territoire lui est favorable bah bien
sûr bah écoutez regardez dans les
Alpes-Maritimes en plus ça me rafraîchit
un peu la mémoire enfin je peux imaginer
que dans les Alpes-Maritimes il y a eu
beaucoup d'adhésions ces derniers temps
bon ensuite une fois que vous craignez
des irrégularités
on va retourner là-dedans non non mais
c'est légitimement c'est des périodes
qui qui chacun fait campagne c'est alors
là franchement c'est pas moi qui vais
dire que quand on fait campagne on fait
campagne Jacques Chirac il nous a appris
ça mais ce que je veux vous dire
simplement c'est que ça fausse un petit
peu la représentation d'un électorat à
droite pas élèves d'un électorat à
droite parce que les Français sont
majoritairement à droite le sévi peuvent
encore montré qu'ils sont à droite sur
les questions régaliennes qui est
incontestablement l'échec de d'Emmanuel
Macron quoi qu'il en dise et Eric Ciotti
se produit il est tout à fait légitime
parce que ayant fait le parcours qu'il a
fait je vois bien pour lui la logique
d'être candidat comme je vous l'ai dit
moi je m'inquiète parce que je trouve
que les choses ne sont pas claires de
son point de vue sur cette question de
la relation avec les Zemmour Marion Le
Pen etc et que ça c'est un vrai risque
après de l'autre côté Bruno Retailleau
il a une candidature qui est tout à fait
légitime pour ma part je la regarde avec
intérêt parce que je vois derrière cela
mais si on a des divergences importantes
notamment sur la somme de questions de
société mais néanmoins elle une autre
vision au débat et je pense que
l'échange entre les deux sera
intéressant quoi qu'il arrive voilà et
ça je pense que nous avons là entre
Bruno Retailleau et Eric Ciotti un
échange qui sera de toute façon
le retour de la guerre des chefs comme
ça a été le cas entre vous et François
Fillon
pour toute une série de raisons que je
ne vais malheureusement pas avoir le
temps sinon les parents
juste une précision depuis Christian
Jacob à la tête DLR la règle avait
changé c'était de dire le président des
républicains ne peut pas être le
candidat non c'est pas naturel
ou cette idée elle va perdurer
que le prochain président de la
républicain peut aussi bien sûr le
candidat naturel
[Musique]
c'est pas la mienne non ça c'est sûr que
c'est la mienne mais encore une fois
chacun la sienne et tout ça est très
bien non mais
attendez
ou Jean Dupont ou Jacques Durand c'est
tout simplement parce que je considère
que parler aujourd'hui de désigner notre
candidat à la présidentielle c'est bien
sympathique mais on oublie juste un
petit détail c'est que la présidentielle
elle n'est pas la semaine prochaine les
dents 5 ans et que à partir du moment où
Laurent Wauquiez la fait le choix de ne
pas être candidat bah il a ouvert le jeu
ce qu'ils sont le choix le son c'est
tout à fait respectable mais il a ouvert
le jeu voilà et quand à eriki bah il a
pris une position qui peut peut-être
être lié au fait du contexte électoral
du moment ils se disent si je peux
récupérer les voix de Rhône-Alpes ou
certaines voix de Ronald ou je ne sais
quoi voilà
c'est trop tôt pour vous
le dernier mot sur un tout autre sujet
genre photocopie puisque ce week-end ont
lieu les Journées du Patrimoine et je
crois qu'il y a un petit événement du
côté de moi autour du château
il se trouve que Jean-Claude Brialy qui
est disparu il y a 15 ans a fait
donation de son château à la ville de
Meaux et que celle-ci est maintenant en
pleine propriété pour la ville de Meaux
puisque son compagnon est décédé et que
nous allons donc donner le coup d'envoi
de la rénovation de ce château qui est
déjà très très bien entretenu il y a
beaucoup de très belles choses et il y
aura une ouverture au public tout le
week-end de du château lui-même et puis
bien entendu du domaine qui est
absolument magnifique et on y trouve des
objets assez extraordinaires qui ont
appartenu à tous les grands comédiens
artistes de la nouvelle vague il y a le
piano de Barbara il y a des objets qui
ont appartenu à de très très nombreuses
artistes des manuscrits des lettres des
photos et puis c'est un endroit où
beaucoup de choses se sont passées Romy
Schneider il y a passé ses les six
derniers mois de sa vie beaucoup
d'artistes y ont séjourné c'est milieu
d'histoires du cinéma et du spectacle
assez exceptionnel et nous allons le
l'ouvrir au public pour la première fois
et on invite la signature
pour les Journées du Patrimoine merci
Jean-François Copé merci
évidemment un très beau musée merci de
visiteurs depuis 10 ans merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité la Une de
westfrance elvage La Ferme France face
aux défis climatique c'est à la Une de
votre journal merci beaucoup Stéphane
merci Jean-François Copé
[Musique]